Because at 1 moment too much is too much but too much is too much.
But what's too much.
Me, me, I,
I defend 1 forgotten world.
I defend this rural world which today has only homework and no rights,
which has a lying anger like that and which we see
everywhere and which comes out of the ballot box.
Now you're talking about farmers,
but not just farmers.
Because in that case,
how do you explain that you have so many
people voting around very hard extreme votes,
even in the small French countryside where I am.
Sorry,
there are not many immigration problems,
there are not many insecurity problems,
but then,
but the discomfort is much deeper than that.
You stigmatize extreme voting,
that's not at all.
Well if you mean uh well that's it.
It's not surprising that there are people who vote,
but I differ from them.
I can very well be 1 Jew without being 1 extremist.
Today it has become 1 dirty word.
To be honest is that they will have values.
There are armors, right.
This is a lie. Yes,
there are identitarians,
there are neutrals,
but I find that French cultural identity is
something strong that I defend and it does not shock me.
And that's not shocking.
Europe to do it.
Some people today, you know,
the biggest problem is more its transmission than anything else.
Some people are thinking,
could I still pass on to my children what I received from my parents.
It can look all stupid and make people laugh in the trays.
In the meantime,
that's what people say so kids say tomorrow?
Will you still be able to fish?
Are you still going on the back of a horse tomorrow?
Will you still be able to eat meat tomorrow?
Well,
it's worse than anything we can imagine,
the transmission.
That's what we're here for.